[Music]
hi and welcome to episode 187 of the
weekly Google cloud platform podcast I
am John and I am here with my colleague
mark hey Mark how's it going hey John
how are ya I'm doing pretty good got
stung by a bee for the first time I
don't know what happened
as soon as I walked outside it was like
you never been stung by a bee let's
check that off the list right on the ear
you know I get the feeling that's
probably not on most people's bucket
lists but maybe that's a great thing you
can now put it on there and then check
it off and say look it happened I may as
well take credit for it right I survived
the heatwave that just passed in New
York so it was pretty pretty hot but
luckily I do pretty good in the heat
yeah it's brutal weather lately with the
exception of of course San Francisco
which is pretty generally 68 and sunny
right so I'd feel very fortunate to live
in San Francisco obviously hopefully
everyone does well with the weather out
there but if not come to San Francisco
i'ma have to come out there and spend a
couple weeks out there we're getting in
some rematches for our smash for this
game too definitely
so in this episode we're gonna sit down
with our day from instruct along with
Sandeep from Google about what instruct
does in the awesome arcade machines that
came out at Nix those were really really
fun to play with yeah we saw a huge
crowd standing around the developer zone
and kind of playing around with well a
bunch of old-school arcade machines so
if you want to hear more about what
those machines were and what instruct
does then definitely stay tuned for the
main content and we're going to get into
our question of the week which is I kind
of want to get more familiar with Google
cloud how do I'd really navigate the
space for material and what kind of
offerings really will help me ramp up
really quickly oh there's so many and
I've heard this question a number of
times you know recently so happy to dive
into and share a few more details on
that all right well first let's move on
to actually talking about our cool
things of the week
[Applause]
so the first thing that came to my mind
was pretty interesting was there was a
project called white board that came out
of area 120 which is Google's
experimental lab and what it is it's a
structured identity blind evaluation
process platform for interviewing that
allows managers to reliably trust
recommendations and candidates get to
work through interviews at their own
pace without the stress of going through
high pressure
theoretical tests so none of those
questions like how many golf balls fit
inside of a school bus or things like
that design ten uses for a manhole cover
in the apocalypse
it was always stuff like that that got
me and it was like this is a really
interesting interview I'm not sure if I
understand what they're going for but
I'll try my personal favorite is the egg
dropping I love that question
Oh egg dropping yeah so you get to drop
an egg I think once or twice you have to
figure out what's the highest floor you
can drop the egg without it breaking or
something like that oh I don't know that
one but I'm sure there's no no shortage
of all those kind of horizontal thinking
questions we're very very interesting to
look at for the interview process right
well away from that one of the things
that came across my table quite a few
times in the past week has been this
Gartner announcement that Google Cloud
is a leader in the infrastructure as a
Service Magic Quadrant space now for
most people it probably doesn't mean a
lot to them because it's not gonna you
know change what you're doing or change
what's out there on Google cloud but I
think it's a really cool you know
recognition that Google is doing some
very very fun things in the
infrastructure as a service base but if
you look at the blog post you can see
some other customers that are taking
advantage of cool things that Google are
doing and hopefully that's kind of some
inspiration for you to look at all these
different services they're out there all
these different tools and saying well
hey what can I build with that I think
that a lot of our developers who are
just getting into the space when you get
recognized kind of like this it helps
them build almost like a reputation for
us so I'm pretty excited to actually be
named a leader in that space yeah it's
pretty awesome so the next cool thing
that come out is bike Sharon's becoming
pretty pretty big in a lot of major
cities and Google has actually been able
to share real-time bike share
information you
Google Maps so there are roughly around
1600 bike-share systems and almost 18
million shared bikes in urban cities so
since the so mainstream now imagine
being able to use Google Maps to find
locations exactly where to find bikes
when they're available and the bell
curve that usually see when you see how
busy a certain stations going to be with
bikes so it's pretty awesome to see that
and I'm actually thinking about picking
up bike sharing and something driving
around the city which is kind of funny
when people find out that I actually
have a car in New York City yeah that's
that is not a very common thing there's
nobody drives us too much traffic right
classic well the last cool thing I have
for the week is that we have this cool
little medium post that one of our
customer engineers put out who was able
to show that you're able to take the
cloud shell which is that environment
that gets spun up with your Google Cloud
account that you can go into and do some
semi persistent stuff well you can go
ahead and run Visual Studio code in
there which is an IDE that I think a lot
of people have been talking about the
past year or two as a really cool IDE
that has a lot of features into it well
you can just kind of run that directly
from your cloud shell environment so you
go in there you download code server and
set it up and now you have a web IDE
that is Visual Studio code so this is a
really really cool way to offload the
you know kind of the IDE and code aspect
from your computer onto the cloud so a
lot of things to Christian he's for
putting up this blog post that shows how
easy it is that's awesome especially
with some systems that don't allow you
to install videos to your code I'm not
sure if Chromebooks actually we're in
Vizier's to your code but if you can't
install visual studio code on a
Chromebook you know whether you're using
Linux or not it'd be awesome just to do
it in Google Cloud show so definitely a
great blog posts and thanks for the
information
yeah very very cool to be portable and
have that power wherever you go well
that was awesome great chatting with you
now let's talk with Sandeep and our day
and see what they have to talk to us
about these arcade machines
[Music]
all righty then thank you so much for
joining us Sade and Sandeep first things
first
okay why don't you tell us a little bit
about yourself and who you are and what
you do sure my name is Johnny muffler
I'm a CTO and co-founder of instruct and
instructors a learning platform for
technology can you go a little in depth
as to exactly the type of things and
struct teaches yeah definitely so what
we believe in struct is that learning is
done best by doing so especially in
technologies things change so fast I
need to keep up and the quickest way to
learn new technologies actually just
play with it and that's exactly what
structs offers you so what we are able
to do with instructs we are able to spin
up training environments send boxes and
give people challenges to solve using
technology and in that process we
validate that what they are doing is
correct and guide them in the right way
in the right direction if they're get
stuck awesome can you maybe give us a
little example of the type of courses
you might find on instruct yeah
definitely we have a bunch of courses on
communities of course where you get a
running kubernetes cluster and we ask
you to deploy stuff to fix stuff to
configure stuff but also we have quite a
lot of content on the Hashi Corp
ecosystem console terraform or stuff
like that awesome and I will be trying
to take one of your kubernetes courses
because I need to brush up very fast
cool so it's like a digital classroom
right people can kind of come in they
can study a topic and then they can you
know put their practice to the test by
actually running this stuff in an actual
environment right yeah definitely so
what we do is we give people some some
flesh carts with some information and
then we drop you will write into some
books you have to get your hands dirty
eventually using the technology and I
like that term you used early you kind
of said playing around with it the
reason I think that's super accurate is
because at Google cloud next 2019 if
anybody was there first of all it was
awesome come back next year but second
of all there were a bunch of arcade
cabinets that were also involved in this
process and Sandy you were kind of
involved in organizing this tell us a
little bit more about what the arcade
cabinets have to do with instruct yeah
sure so funny enough I was in Hamburg
Germany for a conference and I saw this
arcade machine it's kind of hanging out
in the corner I was like what is that
turns out the instructor folks were
there too and they had one of these
machines and said they had some some
developer challenges there and we just
had so much time like a bunch of people
who have crowded around this little
arcade machine and we try to outdo each
other to run a HTTP server with just
code golfing away like the fastest way
we could do it and like getting the
highest scores and I was like this is so
much fun we need one of these at GCP
next so then got in contact with
instruct folks and we work together to
actually bring some Google cloud games
to Google cloud next on the instruct
platform running all these arcade
machines that's not a mouthful haha you
tell me but basically we take the
instructor platform and today and team
have put it on these arcade machines and
gamified it maybe those 80s or retro
kind of theme and then my team we took a
bunch of games based on GCP so odd
functions bigquery all these GCB
technologies and then ported them to the
instruct platform so then attendees
could play them on the show floor which
was a lot of fun and I think that we saw
a tremendous amount of people at next
kind of hanging around those arcade
machines just like you said I want to
get back to how they were set up next
but I guess on it the question is who
thought of the arcade machines how did
that come about
yeah yes so there was actually one of
our developers that the subsoil for
brain wave where we thought they need to
do something different at conferences
you can quite easily get a booth and get
a stand and hangout and give people
stickers or something but we thought
let's do something different let's bring
in our KP into a conference and we got
start thinking so what do we need to do
to get this working get this contraction
we have a house designer we pitched the
idea to him he basically said this is a
great idea I'm gonna build this machine
for you it's a custom build so I built
the physical thing and you guys have to
build the software around that that's
exactly what we did and we brought it to
a different conference basically we put
it there and the traction was amazing so
everybody wants to see what this thing
is about basically our target audience
they grew up in the 70s and the 80s
right and everybody knows arcade
machines everybody has played arcade
games and everybody loves them so the
moment people see arcade machine they're
instantly drawn to it but then you walk
up to it and you see hey there's
something different about this arcade
cabinet this one has keyboards so what's
going on
people approach it they blush it starts
and they see this different kind of
content more serious games but still
games people just love that I definitely
did I actually had access to the
showcase floor prior to next and the
first thing I saw when I came down the
escalator was those arcade machines and
I definitely walked up that's where I
met a day for the first time and I just
hung around for maybe two hours or so
and just let you know guys I am that
game guy so you guys definitely caught
my attention immediately as soon as I
showed up but my question is although
you've been enticing a lot of people by
creating these arcade machines and you
know drawing them in can you tell us
almost like the motivation as to why you
use the machines I know that we wanted
to entice people when we went to add a
keyboard but what really draws people to
continue to keep playing the games once
they get on the keyboard because it is a
different type of game yeah it is
different okay but we do use
gamification elements like a leaderboard
like different challenges like a
validation step where you actually get
to see whether what you're doing is
correct and all those elements that make
people come back to the arcade games try
to beat their own high scores try to top
the leaderboards
so those are all elements that really
draw people to these machines can ii add
to that at next one of the really cool
things that happened it was people came
back multiple times to try to like beat
each other's scores and kept like I can
get higher than you I can get higher
than you and so the leaderboards just
kept going up and up and people were
really excited about that that's awesome
so can you tell us a little bit more
about why you decided to gamify things
like learning by doing I guess would be
like the best definition for it
so the idea originated in a conference
that we co-organized together with
Harsha Corp so they organized the first
EU conference in Amsterdam and we work
organizing and we thought let's do
something different we need to get the
tools of harsha corp into the hands of
their users so we create a little bit of
a competition platform very similar to
what you currently see on the arcade
machines or an instructor's comb what we
gave them sandbox environments with some
challenges around terraform console no
matter vault and we asked them to solve
it purely the focus was a competition
platform and it was such a big success
that people even went back to the hotel
because there was better Wi-Fi to
actually solve the challenges
but a lot of feedback that we also got
this this is a great way to learn new
technology because a lot of people they
may be touched one of these tools but
not all for and we got people into
contact with different tools that they
never knew about and they learned a lot
about it so that feedback got us
thinking so this is maybe very good way
to learn new technology and make it into
a learning platform rather than just a
competition platform so on one side
you've got the arcade machines now which
it sounds like are pretty popular way
right I mean any arcade machine that
doesn't require quarters I think will
get a pretty big audience but you've
also combined it with these online labs
in these different experiences how does
the platform where you actually set up
those labs how is that actually built so
we build on top of kubernetes we use a
load of goaling in our backends we use
reax for the front-end and we use a lot
of terraform to basically make the
platform that happen that in combination
with some brush here and there maybe a
little bit too much but that's how the
internet works right hey bash is this
the glue of the internet yeah definitely
don't bash on math but I seriously love
bash if it weren't for bash I would be
lost probably but it's worth a little
small team 430 with five people we tried
to use as many managed services as
possible so for kubernetes we use gke
for database we use cloud sequel for
builds environments we use cloud build
for our certification firebase
authentication so as many managed
services as possible so we can focus on
things that are important for us is how
to spin up the sandbox is how to present
it to the users or stuff like that it's
not the first time that you know we've
kind of seen a company try to teach all
the technologies and they found that the
best way to teach it is also to run on
those same technologies so it's always
super interesting to hear about yeah you
know I mean what's the best way to teach
kubernetes is to get the manage
communities environment and then you run
your infra on there - yeah definitely
I think if you want to start teaching
you have to learn it first so you have
to learn about this technology and what
you get a grip on it then you can start
teaching other people then you really
start to learn about this technology the
best way to learn in my opinion is to
teach others because you have to go into
a much greater level of detail to
understand what you're actually doing to
be able to explain it to different
people absolutely so send
how did that translate into the work
that you kind of led and some of the
other developer advocates here and
developer program engineer has worked on
yeah so the challenge that we faced was
how to make you know traditionally quote
unquote boring enterprise platform you
know fun and exciting and so instruct
kind of helps with that by having these
like checks as odd a calls them so every
step of the way that platform actually
runs code on their side to check that
you actually completed whatever task was
set for you right so you can't just
cheat your way through the games so that
was really powerful being able to like
run code to check what they did spinning
up their own sandbox to like have them
experiment and have like a no guide
rails right so with that the things like
our gke challenge they could either you
know used to kuberan a CLI they could
write it in a ya know file like choices
was there some how they solved these
problems so that gave us as a team a lot
of flexibility and designing them right
we didn't have to be like kind of forced
into any sort of pattern like as long as
it worked on the command line like we
could use it on the instruct platform
and I found that really powerful yeah
it's not just commands Leidner stuff
that you can do we also have an option
to run you eyes maybe not as effectively
of new york' machines but our normal
platform does run you eyes as well as
allows us to to expose basically any web
app or even desktop sessions to users
which makes you really powerful so we
actually used instructs ability to run
arbitrary apps and connect them to their
back-end to run a full RPG in the
instruct arcade machine so it was almost
like there was actual video game running
in the arcade machines that taught you
about coding is inception in many levels
first we're teaching people about the
environment running on that actual
environment now we're basically just
modeling being real life this is kind of
a funny question maybe aa day will
answer this so if I were richer arcade
machine and I just do up up down down
left right left right BA what would
happen unfortunately I remember back I
think it was eight or nine years ago my
previous company we did have that code
on our website it would start showing my
little pony figures on the website oh I
remember that javascript library it was
a fun one to add yeah we've talked about
the
the platform and how its built in all
the technologies around it but I'm
curious what other technologies do you
actually support in these sand boxes so
we support quite a wide range of
technology so in the basis we can run
containers and virtual machines but we
also have the ability to start a
complete new Google cloud project or an
AWS account and we're also looking at
adding different cloud vendors as well
and we can mix and match all these
different technologies so that gives you
a lot of freedom a lot of flexibility to
create arbitrarily complex environments
to basically create an environment to
teach your users whatever you need and
I'm curious when you're actually working
in technologies in the sandbox is how do
you actually create these sand boxes and
what kind of challenges do you actually
have when you're creating them so the
definition of the sandbox is is just a
simple yellow file that we defined so
there you can specify your containers or
your virtual machines or whatnot and you
can use standard images from the docker
hub for instance or from Google Cloud
compute images and then we have a set of
scripts that we can run on these
containers or virtual machines those are
simple bash scripts and they get
executed on that infrastructure in that
sandbox that you defined so you can
basically do arbitrary complex setups or
simulations or whatever you need to do
maybe a breaker cluster and ask people
to fix it that's all possible was there
anything that you tried to set up either
than the kind of the more traditional
classroom approach or maybe through the
arcade machines that just didn't quite
land right the first thing that we
always have to do is the more
enterprises so far because it tends to
be slow to start and difficult to
configure automatically but I don't
think there's anything that we
encountered that we could not do
eventually you know with a lot of
hacking a lot of testing and trial and
error we usually get stuff running that
and more bash right
yeah so what's next for the arcade
machines I mean they're already
obviously a pretty big hit but where are
they gonna go next go for con next week
which I don't know when this podcast is
coming out okay if you're listening to
this before then make sure you go if
you're listening after make sure to
check out the website and if you're
listening while it's going on just fly
right out there mark not all of us have
private jets you know yeah we're working
on that right but we also got well
Booker T we have the seven arcade
machines at Google in the States right
but there's going to be more arcade
machines in Europe and then in Asia as
well so maybe you can tell a little bit
more about that Sandeep yeah so we're
trying to get our kid machines and many
of the cloud summits around the world if
you're in one of those cities in you're
planning on attending a Google cloud
summit keep your eye out for an arcade
machine other open source conferences
and stuff that we sponsor we're trying
to get these in the hands of as many
people as possible so yeah keep your eye
out no matter where you are in the world
and I assume the next iteration is going
to involve VR right I mean as a kid
playing arcade machines I know that
stepping into that world would be super
cool you know I mean there's nothing
quite like blasting aliens but from like
a first-person perspective so now we
just need to be able to spin up
kubernetes clusters from a first-person
perspective it puts a whole new
dimension to wake up all right
very very cool well thank you all so
much for coming in and telling us a
little bit about it we're almost out of
time here is there anything you want to
call out or talk a bit more about before
we wrap up so we do have an open
platform anyone can start playing for
free start learning for free at
instructive comb we even have an option
to create content yourself so just reach
out to us at hello at instructors comb
we'll get you started
creating some cool content awesome well
ah dai thanks so much for talking about
all the cool things instruc does and
Sandeep I mean great job on leading that
effort I think a lot of people got some
really really cool hands-on experience
at Google cloud next and hopefully
people who can make it out to gopher con
and other conferences worldwide will be
able to kind of get their hands on these
arcade machines very cool thank you
definitely alright mark so our question
of the week is
I want to be more for me we'll go cloud
how do i navigate the space for the
material so what do you got for us so
there's a lot of space here and I think
that there's been quite a few people who
I've heard you know they see this
different information on Twitter on
social posts and I'm sure it's a little
confusing so let me give you a quick
rundown I would say the number one thing
right now is that there's a
certification challenge going on and
this certification challenge is
basically you committing to saying I'm
gonna teach myself this stuff in three
months and then if I get certified
within those three months either with
the cloud architecture or the data
engineer certification you get $100 for
Google merch that's pretty cool not to
mention the certifications come with
some swag of their own and like a
backpack or a hoodie so you kind of have
that power but you're probably in it for
more than just the swag you're hopefully
also wanting to learn about the cloud so
there's a mix of different environments
in quick labs in Coursera quick labs are
a great place to start they'll organize
things in quests and these are all
interactive labs that you spin up you
can work with directly they create a
sandbox environment for you and then
when the lab is done you shut it down so
these are very hands-on very simple ways
to actually get through some of these
skills and practice what they look like
on the Coursera side they're a little
bit more organized in terms of there's
videos there's text content and then
there's some hands-on labs as well but
that has a lot longer breadth of kind of
detail you go into so with the Google
cloud certification challenge each path
has a list of recommended quick labs and
Coursera courses that you can go through
feel comfortable set up a schedule for a
three-month process where you're taking
these things your training and of course
you're practicing and then at the end
you take that certification and if it
all passes you get that hundred dollars
just bet so to kind of summarize for
getting started I'd recommend taking the
certification challenge looking at the
quick labs and Coursera recommended
courses and labs respectively and then
figuring out how can I make the time for
this over the next three months to win
that cool merch that's really awesome I
am spending my time I'm taking it slowly
doing my certification but it's kind of
good to actually give our developers who
wants to get certified some incentive
trust me when I tell you that some of
the merch that people that people get
when they pass these certifications I
really awesome like those blue puffer
jackets that they were walking around
with necks were pretty pretty awesome
yeah it was it was super cool to see and
I think people were excited to see all
the different available things I think
it next they were even giving out like
little medals that you could hang around
your neck if you yeah and certified
there right if it were up to me what I
would get is just continuing to buy
multiple Android figurines I love
collecting those things oh there's so
many out there now you know we need is
we need a cloud figurine I think we have
one actually I'll send a picture but I
would really like a new right well take
this up to marketing and for anyone
who's listening to this podcast just
give me some time oh they should do a
contest like design your own oh you need
to start with deciding the first one
then we can get them to design their own
right right so uh mark where are you
gonna be where are you traveling to knit
oh yeah I've got a fun little few days
in the East Coast so I'm gonna fly
across and hopefully the heat wave
breaks by then we'll have to see and
then I'll be flying out to Austin where
I think it is perpetually pretty warm to
talk to some customers there and
hopefully get a fun podcast or video
recording out of it how about yourself I
will be speaking at PAX dev in August
which is pretty awesome and I get to
attend PAX West as well so I'll be there
in Seattle end of August going into
September
very very cool what's your talk on at
PAX dev my talk is on Universal
communication and its benefits and games
give us a sneak preview a lot of people
quit games based on the fact that
sometimes there's a language barrier
especially people who are in countries
that are not their own and they're
trying to play games so instead of
waiting multiple hours for their servers
to be live or you know just not talking
creating some type of universal
communication where they can communicate
with their team and speak comfortably in
their own language would be kind of
awesome so I'm gonna explore that space
and show how it may benefit games
especially when you have multi regional
games super cool so remember people if
you're going to be a pax dev check out
that talk and I'm sure there's going to
be lots of other talks as well probably
tons of great content there should be
fun awesome so
thank you all for listening and we hope
to all see you next week have fun mark
we'll see ya
[Music]
turning up the volume turning up the
volume what you're saying is Sandeep
you're pumping up those jams
[Music]